hey youtubers it's Charlie so there's
been a whole bunch of Marvel news lately
really big stuff mostly about ant-man
and Doctor Strange but they basically
just said that they're making sweeping
changes to the way they introduce new
characters to the Marvel movie universe
so this video is mostly gonna be a
breakdown of that but then I'll talk
about some of the cool stuff that's
going on behind the scenes of ant-man
and the Doctor Strange movie lots of
cool stuff to get through so let's start
with the most important stuff no more
Marvel origin stories here is basically
what happened there are currently 30
comic book films from all the studio's
being released between now and 2020
that's 30 tentpole big-budget movies
every six years that's totally crazy and
if you look at the model that the
studio's used for making movies about
new characters like Marvel Fox Sony all
of them you really start to see why
they're dropping origin stories it makes
a lot of sense given all these new films
that are coming Doctor Strange just
happens to be the first Marvel movie
that's gonna adhere to this rule and if
you guys really want you can let me know
but I'll do a video just for all 30 of
those comic book films it's crazy it's a
super long list I just didn't want to do
it in this video this is basically what
used to happen when a studio had a
character or team that it wanted to
start a new franchise for like Avengers
you have your origin story movie first
then the sequel with more villains you
stuff more villains into the second
movie and then another sequel like the
third movie where the hero crashes and
burns emotionally and then you get the
team up movie the Avengers movie it's a
formula that every single studio has
used for new comic book characters and
it's been happening since Tim Burton's
Batman movies in the spider-man
franchise the first spider-man franchise
it's been a long time since then Tim
Burton's first Batman film was 1989
Marvel in their infinite wisdom with all
the movies they just announced felt like
people would get sick of that formula
you know after 20 plus origin story
movies people just wouldn't care as much
anymore
so in response starting with Doctor
Strange Marvel will no longer introduce
new comic book characters in origin
stories what does that mean in real life
that just means that when we go into the
theater and see the Doctor Strange movie
he's already gonna be sorcerer supreme
at the beginning of the film just to
explain where the movies at right now
they have a director named Scott
Derrickson and a writer named John
Speights he's actually the guy that
wrote Prometheus for Ridley Scott so
depending on how you felt about
Prometheus that's a good thing or a bad
thing those are relatively recent
developments but here's what's happened
with the movie so far at the studio
they've had an in-house script for a
long time
Marvel hires teams of writers that just
comb through their catalogue of
characters and try to develop scripts
for characters that haven't been used in
the movies yet isn't in-house writing
programs that they've had for a long
time that's actually how guardians of
the galaxy ended up becoming a movie a
female writer inside the program named
Nicole Perlman thought that guardians
would make a great movie so she wrote a
script Marvel liked that script so much
that they sent it out to directors until
James Gunn accepted and signed on to the
project he rewrote that original script
and the same thing is totally happening
on the Doctor Strange movie right now
scott derrickson and john Speights are
just rewriting the original script it
was written to be an origin story so
since Marvel's not doing that anymore
they naturally just have to throw that
script out and write something totally
new the new script they're working on
will structurally look more like Batman
Begins or a Man of Steel it'll still
deal with origins but only in flashbacks
and it's kind of funny and it makes it
seem like Marvel's copying something
that DC and Warner Brothers has done but
that's not what's actually going on like
they're not copying Christopher Nolan
it's just that Batman Begins is a good
example of an origin story that's not
told like a traditional origin story
even guardians of the galaxy already
skipped a lot of the characters origins
you see star-lord as a child for like
five minutes before it picks up with him
as a fully actualized scoundrel slash
hero let me know how you guys feel about
this would you rather see you know all
these new comic book characters like
Black Panther Doctor Strange
show up as like actual superheroes in
the movie or do you want to see the
origin story first like do you want to
see them become that hero the thing that
would be missing from a lot of these
films would be the hero
learning to use his powers for the first
time like that's typically one of the
biggest montages of origin stories
honestly I think that just given the 30
films that we're gonna be seeing in the
next six years it's gonna be a fresh
change of pace I think it'll be a good
thing they can still totally do origin
stories just as like digital content or
like Marvel one-shots like something
they would include with the DVD release
and that original Doctor Strange script
wasn't terrible I mean Marvel liked it
enough to send it out to directors it
was written by the guy who wrote Sahara
the Matthew McConaughey movie that was
actually a pretty terrible movie you can
insert any joke that you want but the
original script the origin story
featured more dough as the main villain
and followed the original comic book
origin story pretty faithfully there was
an animated movie that did another
version of the origin story
if you haven't seen it it's just as good
as any of the other Marvel animated
films I think it's streaming on Netflix
right now so you guys can watch it if
you want you guys may have also heard
about all the recent accurate changes
around Doctor Strange they actually
found their person but because he did
not sign his contract before Comic Con
they haven't announced it yet the
biggest rumors lately were Joaquin
Phoenix and Jared Leto Benedict
Cumberbatch made some jokes during his
panel at Comic Con he'd be my pick and
he has been in talks with the studio but
next year whenever they'd be shooting
the movie he's actually gonna be doing
Hamlet so it's a schedule conflict so I
don't think that Benedict Cumberbatch is
gonna be able to be Doctor Strange even
if you wanted to and if they're gonna go
with someone like Joaquin Phoenix I
think ditching the origin story is a
good idea too
I think he's really good for like the
crazy sorcerer supreme dr. strange I
don't think he'd be as good for the
Stephen strange doctor it's also totally
possible that the actor they want hated
that origin story script and that's part
of us holding things up sometimes actors
won't sign on to a project if they think
the script is terrible the movie is
scheduled for release in 2016 right now
so if they're gonna start shooting next
year like they'd have to start shooting
next year they're gonna have to find
their man in the next couple of months
so we should all expect some sort of
casting news at least before December
I'd say speaking of shooting on to
ant-man they just started filming this
week in San Francisco and released this
picture it's basically from day one of
them filming on the set just to compare
the Fantastic Four reboot movie has
finished filming like they're totally
done with that movie and they have not
released any images or any promo art it
just makes you appreciate how open
Marvel is with their projects like they
don't have to show us things but they
totally do what the picture shows is
obviously Paul Rudd asked Scott Lang in
a van down by the river kind of looking
like he's a homeless man the thought is
is that they change the previous ant-man
script and they're being a little bit
more faithful to the comic book origins
the original script had him working at
Hank PIMs company along with
yellowjacket they explained some of the
details of the Comic Con panel so I'll
be sure to link that video in the
description now it seems like Paul
Rudd's version of the character is just
gonna be much more faithful to the
comics he's gonna be a common criminal
stealing stuff to pay for his daughter's
medical bills he was always a brilliant
scientist he just became a common
criminal to help his family survive he
ended up stealing the ant-man costume
and eventually Hank Pym passed the torch
there was another video I did a while
ago where I kind of explained the
ant-man origin story and just a
little bit greater to tell so I had
another link for that in the description
too it's a pretty straightforward origin
story he first appeared in the comics
during Avengers 181 in 1979 and
officially took the mantle of ant-man in
Marvel premiere 47 later that year so
you should definitely check those comics
out and in a funny twist of fate Matt
Fraction started using him again the
Scott Lang character in his Fantastic
Four comic in 2012 and it was funny that
I compared the Fantastic Four reboot
movie to the ant-man movie but that was
just a coincidence I'm really hoping to
see Paul Rudd in the future Avengers
movie that's why I'm not gonna happen
during Avengers 2 but he was part of the
team in the comics maybe by the time
they get around to Avengers 3 he'll show
up on the roster Marvel has announced
that they will be changing the Avengers
roster between age of Ultron in the
third movie to many new characters will
be around by then for them to not
include them and we also have to
consider that there might be actors
leaving the franchise like stop being
their characters like samuel l.jackson
and robert downey jr they're currently
like the most senior members at Marvel
films right now that's actually a pretty
good question to end on which core
Avenger do you think will be the first
to leave their role like stop being
their character in the movies personally
my bets on Robert Downey jr. just
because he's currently only signed to
one more movie and that's Avengers 3
that was part of the deal that he signed
Avengers 2 in vengers 3 and that's it
unless they sign a new contract just
because I haven't done in a while
tomorrow I'm gonna do a Marvel Q&A video
so feel free to ask me any Marvel
related question you want it doesn't
have to be about the movies but be sure
to subscribe to get that video I've also
got an arrow season 3 video I'm working
on for tomorrow - it's gonna be a
villains video they just announced
comodo so I'll explain him and some of
the other big season 3 villains but
right now you can click here to get that
Q&A I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it and you can click here to learn
all about Marvel's Inhumans movie that's
probably gonna be one of the other phase
3 movies thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives
you